to the US now where President Joe
Biden's son Hunter Biden has agreed to
plead guilty to tax charges and has
admitted to illegally owning a gun let's
meet Patty culhane she joins us live now
from Washington D.C Patty what more do
we know about these charges
well we'll get to that in just one
second but I want to give you a broader
perspective this has a long been a focus
of Republican
politicians really trying to paint
Hunter Biden and therefore Joe Biden his
father the president as corrupt Donald
Trump particularly has been laser
focused on this you'll remember his
first impeachment was because he
withheld military aid to Ukraine because
he said he wanted them to get dirt on
Hunter Biden that he could use in the
campaign so this investigation was
launched under President Donald Trump's
his attorney general in Delaware has
been looking into Hunter Biden what we
believe now is that Hunter Biden is
going to plead guilty to the misdemeanor
charges of not paying his taxes on time
that was in 2017 and 2018. we believe
that he's paid back about 1.2 million
dollars and for that it's he's going to
get probation now the other issue came
up during the investigation he filed
papers to basically be able to buy a
handgun and on that form it says do you
use drugs are you a drug addict and he
wrote no but then he later wrote a book
saying that during that time he was
frequently using crack cocaine so the
what they've decided to do is basically
he'll go into a diversion program that
helps people with substance abuse
problems if he stays clean for two years
then that felony conviction will be
right wiped off of his record so it
appears as of right now that this case
this long-running investigation is going
to be settled with no jail time for the
president's son as you mentioned the
just now the Republicans are likely to
capitalize it on it they have been
already how might it impact Joe Biden as
he runs for re-election
well I can tell you Republican
politicians particularly in the house
have really been laser focused on this
they've been having hearings trying to
find broader uh alleged crimes that
Hunter Biden has committed so far uh in
all of their hearings they've come up
with absolutely nothing that would paint
a hunter Biden or Joe Biden in a bad
light they are unlikely to stop that
they say the investigations are going to
continue Republican media is going to
say look he's getting off so easy and
look what's happening to president
Donald Trump even though the severity of
their alleged crimes are completely
different for Joe Biden and Jill Biden
his wife they put out a statement saying
that they're not going to comment on
this that they love and support their
son as he recovers from addiction but it
does allow the Biden campaign to sort of
put this away they can say look when we
came to office we left in the Trump
appointed attorney general in Delaware
because we didn't want to be seen as
interfering with the investigation we
wanted it to play out his the the
Attorney General has said he's left all
of the decisions to that attorney
general in Delaware so Biden can say
look it's done let's move forward I
support my son but it doesn't mean the
Republicans are going to drop it because
they clearly are not going to okay bring
us the latest on that Hunter Biden story
thanks very much Patty